Oh
there are a lot of times when I
discourage people from doing press I
have a number of celebrities I represent
and we run a risk of overexposure that
people get tired of them and that goes
to back to warhol and the way we cover
celebrities now I call the reality the
reality show coverage of celebrities we
only have so many slots we only have so
much time and entertainment tonight or
showbiz tonight so we generally pick a
number of celebrities somewhere around
25 celebrities and we may cover them at
any given time over the last couple
years it seemed to be Paris and Brittney
and Lindsey but now we're not seeing
them quite as much as we did because we
get tired of them we get burned out in
them they get kicked off the island as
we say and then we say well who's coming
in to take their place who's the new
celebrity who's going to do it and it's
interesting because this reality culture
way in which we cover celebrities works
two ways and that is we like we have a
certain limited number of celebrities we
cover the other thing is a regular
person can become a celebrity that's
what we got from reality shows you can
win and suddenly become a celebrity ie
Elisabeth Hasselbeck look she's now
famous and the other thing that reality
shows do is take celebrities and make
them human go watch the real life even
an excellent show like dancing with the
stars that has really helped a lot of
people's images they show those
celebrities in real moments in rehearsal
when they hurt their foot having a hard
time with something and we like that we
like to be more like like celebrities as
regular people and we like our
celebrities to be more like us as
regular people to
what the most common problem in media
training or media coaching as I do it is
people do an interview and they haven't
thought about it ahead of time and they
as I say they're the goalie for the
hockey team and I go how the interview
go and they said hi didn't get my teeth
knocked out and the puck didn't go in
the net behind me so I scored it was a
great interview and to use a sports
analogy if you're doing an interview
you're playing offense you have a reason
for doing that interview and if you
don't have a reason for doing an
interview don't do the interview so if
you have indeed a reason for doing the
interview we deal with the fact that the
media can deal with somewhere between
three and five messages in most
interviews and if you know what those
messages are ahead of time you've
practiced them you practice getting them
out there you've practiced the tough
questions and you do the interview and I
say hey how'd it go they say I got my
messages out I handled the tough
questions well then you have a real
objective measure for that so the
biggest mistake people make is they
don't go in with a plan
I have 30 years of experience on my side
so there's very few situations I haven't
seen before but the one truth is you
know they call it spin doctors right
that's one of the terms people use and I
think it's an apt comparison in a lot of
ways because each person is different in
their DNA in terms of the media one
person can do something in the media and
it plays out a certain way another
person can do the same thing and it
plays out totally different just like
one person could be given a drug and
cure a disease another person could be
given the same drug and it could kill
them and you know there's a lot of gray
areas but experience helps understanding
trends help and there are some basic
truths about how you deal with the media
how you treat people with respect about
your integrity your reputation and my
book is not a blueprint but it is a
process and it allows each person to
adjust for their own foibles their own
realities of their life and I think
that's what's important the first thing
I tell everybody to do is take a
baseline take a pulse if you go see a
doctor he's going to take your pulse
check your heartbeat he's going to take
your temperature he's going to take a
series of tests and say here's where we
stand today I think we all need to do
that with our own public image and you
can do that online you can do that by
talking to people but you want to get a
baseline for your reputation because you
know where you're going to start from
I never think it should be quote unquote
contrived I think it should be authentic
and the point being if I went through
anybody's closet and was choosing a
wardrobe for TV okay the wardrobe that
they're going to wear to a party is
different from the wardrobe they're
going to wear to be interviewed on TV I
want it all to be real I want it all to
be true to them but it's got to be
consistent there are certain actors and
actresses we think of and we go there a
great dresser they always look good
they're always in style and they always
pull it together and there's certain
people we go oh my god they're a
disaster one day they're wearing
something that doesn't flatter the next
thing something that doesn't work on on
TV and it's really knowing what works
for you because I'm I'm 64 250 pounds
what works for me is not going to work
for somebody who is a size 40 regular
model Hugh Jackman and I have decided
not to share wardrobes for that
particular reason and you have to be
really clear on what's going to work for
you and what doesn't work for you and
and understand your own rules I don't
think we have to be contrived I don't
want everybody living a nuanced moment
there's something that your essence when
you're asked a question you don't have
to think about what would my brand do
you can answer honestly if they're
wildly inconsistent it says more about
your personality than it does about your
brand
well in that case I call it the mystique
and the mystique is in accessibility and
it goes to something I talk about in the
book which I'll call the Coors beer
syndrome when I was a kid growing up in
Michigan if somebody went skiing in
Colorado they bring a six pack of coors
beer back in their ski boat and you
would drink this can you go oh my god
this is the best beer I've ever had it's
it's liquid manna from heaven and isn't
this amazing and as soon as they started
selling this Coors beer at every
7-eleven on every corner in every liquor
store it lost its mystique so some
people have a mystique of
inaccessibility and that's smart as long
as they manage it well because if you
could become too inaccessible then
people lose interest so it's always it's
always a balancing act out there and you
never know it's like knowing when the
stock market's going to go up we're
going to go down if you absolutely knew
that you'd make a lot of money but there
are people who have a pretty good
intuitive feel for their own self and
what's out there about them and those
are the people who have a real gift a
real skill set again Brad and Angelina
seem to have that gift
you